-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Woody Harrelson.
So, this is
a fantastic new film.
And from the clip,
we can see there's a lot
of actors with
intellectual disabilities,
and many of whom, obviously,
you've never met before.
Is it true that the first time
you met them was the scene
where you met them in the film?
-Yeah. Yeah, Bobby Farrelly,
who directed it --
you know, it is a comedic
masterpiece, which, you know,
the last time we did
a film together was "Kingpin,"
another comedic masterpiece.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Anyway, he had said
the night before --
he arranged that
to happen like that.
But he had said, "Listen,
you know, we're going to try
to get the scene, but you never
know how things are gonna work.
We might end up throwing
the script out all together."
I break out into a sweat.
I'm like what the f-- heck.
[ Laughter ]
I forgot, network television.
Yeah, no. So, I was --
I got very worried about that
because I'm used
to the context of a script,
and improvising may be inside
of that, but this --
anyway, there was no need
to worry.
I came in.
These guys were just so fun.
And they would come up
with great improvs,
and the whole experience
was just joyful.
And I don't know, I guess --
we call them the friends
in the movie,
and the friends, they speak
the language of the heart,
and that is definitely
a language that I dig.
-Yeah.
They're very -- they come off --
[ Cheers and applause ]
They come off in a really
genuine, authentic way
that a lot of professional
actors have trouble doing.
You know what I mean?
You're watching them and you
just get a sense of this
is just coming right out of
them, just flowing through them.
-Right, right.
-Really nice to see.
-Yeah.
-You and Bobby --
So you worked on "Kingpin"
together,
but you've known each other
forever.
I did not realize you went
way back.
-Literally within the first
week I moved to L.A.,
when I was 23, I met Bobby
and Pete, his brother.
-And I want to talk about
your long history together,
but I did not know
this, as well --
You and Bobby had some --
before you made great films,
inventions.
You had some ideas for
money-making adventures.
-Now, you really have done
your research.
-Yeah, well --
-Because I thought that was
buried ancient history.
-I read a lot of
inventor magazines.
-We did have
an incredible invention,
and it was 6-foot round
beach towel,
so now when the sun moves,
your towel doesn't have to.
[ Laughter ]
So that -- that went huge.
That went huge.
-I think we all remember
that summer where everybody
had a giant circular towel.
-Everyone had the circle.
-How far did you guys
take your --
Did you ever march on down
to the patent office
with your circular-towel idea?
-We did.
-Yeah.
-But, unfortunately,
that didn't make revenue.
[ Laughter ]
You know, it was a great idea,
but we didn't quite get her
across the finish line.
-That's all right.
You know what?
You've had your other successes.
And I wouldn't hold on to that
failure too much, you know?
-You're right.
I mean, I should just let go
of that and just focus
on the good [bleep]
Yeah, totally.
[ Laughter ]
-So, now, you were living
with both Farrellys after --
even after you got cast
in "Cheers"?
-I lived with Pete.
He and I were roommates.
But poor Pete, you know,
before they did
"Dumb and Dumber"...
-Yeah, that was their breakout.
-And then Bobby and I
were working together.
But we were
seeing each other all the time.
We were all such good friends
and a bunch of other
really funny friends of theirs
from Rhode Island.
Anyway, Pete and I, he wanted me
to do "Dumb and Dumber."
Talk about --
How about dumbest, right?
[ Laughter ]
-If you had "Dumb, Dumber,
and Dumbest," I would do that.
But what I did, I said,
"Petey --"
Now, Petey's a real good
pool player,
and I fancy myself
as not bad, either.
Anyway, so, I said,
"Petey, I'll tell you what.
I'm kind of torn.
Let's play a game of pool.
And if I win,
I'm not gonna do it.
If you win, I'll do it."
So, it came down to the 8 ball,
right?
And it's like a shot that's
an insane slice shot
into the pocket that --
you know, most people --
even Willie Mosconi
would have had trouble.
Me, I sink that damn ball.
[ Laughter ]
-Was he kind enough to remind
you about that over the years?
-Holy [bleep]
I don't need any reminder
about that one.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
It's like one of the great
comedies of all time.
-Well, again, you know,
you got that,
you got circular towel,
but otherwise, I think
they've all been hits.
-Let those go, let those go!
-Yeah, let those go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, man, it's always
such a pleasure to see you.
-Yes, Seth, very special.
-Congratulations on everything.
-Good to see you.
-Woody Harrelson.
"Champions" premieres
in theaters on March 10th.
We'll be right back
with Niall Horan.